hello everyone and welcome to another
episode of generation next your weekly
video destination for everything to do
with ps5 and xbox series x
now obviously we've been a bit xbox
focused these last few weeks
um because sony has been very quiet
that is until this week and even then
all the stuff they're giving us has been
doled out in a very strange piecemeal
way so
to help me go through all these little
breadcrumbs of information
i'm joined by the create button to
hussein at this point
absolutely horny for new consoles lads
being horny on main just straight
forward
next week is gonna get real gross so
prepare yourself
and the mysterious playstation ui jordan
remain
what's up
so let's jump right into it guys what do
you make of sony strategy
leading up to the ps5 launch so for
context
when you compare it to xbox xbox had
dummy units that they sent out so they
could uh they basically flooded the
market
uh market the online with pictures of
people having a series x
in their home so you're already like you
can imagine it in your home and then
they sent out
like demo kits weeks before um
the actual launch date in november and
sony
as far as this recording they've given
hands-on to select press in japan
and youtube is in japan um and worldwide
they've released
that uh little tear down video but
there's still so much about it that we
don't know
so what do you guys make of this
strategy
i think i've talked about this before in
um i don't
really understand it um and regardless
of what the strategy is
sony is giving a lot of uh runway to
microsoft right now
um the oxygen around the discussion of
next-gen consoles
is entirely being used by microsoft like
you said
and like we've mentioned a bunch of
times in the past the feeds are flooded
with microsoft
um and currently the issue that sony
faces
is um now is when a lot of people are
making purchasing decisions or making
uh financial decisions based on what
they want to buy going forward
and what they have currently is a xbox
a couple of xbox consoles that they have
a
great deal of information on what it
includes what they'll get how much
they'll pay
the options that they have to pay
for it and and how they can integrate
that into their life because
one thing that we often talk about is
the payment model but um
a lot of things that people need to
consider is if they do use the kind of
like pay monthly model it affects stuff
like credit score and that kind of stuff
because it is like a phone plan so
they can make those decisions whereas
right now they have very little to work
on with sony so effectively all you
really have is
your their track record and your brand
loyalty to kind of make that decision
and maybe some games that might excite
you
i don't know if that's enough for a lot
of people i think there's just enough
like confusion and mystery around what
sony sony's console
is that people could decide they want to
pick microsoft
and i don't think that's the intended
effect that sony wants but it's what
they're kind of getting
out of it which is a shame because
there's probably amazing things
happening on that console that just
we're just not seeing yet
it's funny that you say that because
there has been like a couple things of
like market research coming out that say
that sony is still
dominating uh when it comes to audience
interest which is really
like it's obviously great for sony but
it's still very strange like and
you know i don't want to wade into
console war mindset too much but it is
so strange that like xbox gets
picked up on things like the reaction to
the bethesda acquisition
uh and yet sony are like you know we're
just over a month out and they're still
holding so much back
and everyone is still like yeah it's
fine i'm like
my my heart is with sony so like jordan
you're you're an xbox fan like what do
you make of all this
i mean tam already kind of hit it like
right on the head like it's one of those
things where there are people
like me who are buying an xbox like no
matter what i'm buying on xbox but i'm
waiting to see what playstation
is doing and what the playstation 5
looks like in order to buy one
in the same side there are people who
are definitely buying playstation 5.
they love the ps4 the ps3 the ps2 etc
etc
they're playstation people but it's that
like middle group the undecided
people who are like i can only afford
one next-gen console i can only buy
one of them this holiday season or early
in 2021
and sony's not like giving them i think
enough information to
make that educated decision over which
of those consoles they might
want more my hope in this entire thing
is that
sony somehow is choosing to do this that
they
are choosing to go with this strategy
because the alternative
that they just are going into this next
console generation
so ill prepared and so ill-equipped that
they're basically just doing the bare
minimum
trying to get by is not a possibility
that i like
to think about so i'm hoping that
they're trying to just
ride on the goodwill of the ps4 and
they're like oh yeah enough people will
buy
the playstation 5 because the
alternative that they just aren't ready
for this console generation and they
just don't
have much to show because they're just
not ready to show a lot
is a lot more worrisome we're here to
talk about the nitty-gritty
cause sony have been drip feeding us
information and
some of the stuff that's been coming out
this week it goes from like
super minor and tiny information to
uh to huge stuff like getting to see the
inside of the console so let's
run through uh and ask you guys for your
opinions on all the stuff that we found
out so
this one i'm gonna class tiny
the dual sense differentiates different
players
because the light bar is moved and now
it's on the top
instead of at the back which we already
knew but now we know that it helps
differentiate different players
that's like a weird tiny bit of
information
i'm sorry i don't care so uh
i will make sure this video is linked in
the description below but someone
watched all
of the uh all the japanese influence are
hands-on and kind of basically collated
like the biggest takeaways
biggest takeaways are that the load
times obviously they've been pushing
this for almost a year now but it's like
the low times are almost instant
which is very very exciting and like my
ps4 right now
i love you but it's struggling like it
can barely run
menus right now like i had to take mine
apart because i was so worried about it
i had to like
replace the film or paste on mine and
now it like runs like a dream but like
i shouldn't have to do that yeah i mean
we had a couple weeks ago
where uh we had the footage of my
playstation just attempting to take off
into orbit
uh but the big takeaway from all of
these hands-on is that it's
super super quiet and that
to me is like i can't play warzone
without putting headphones on now
because that's how loud my console gets
it's
you know this is a first um
like in the first wave of playstation
pros before they fix that
issue um and i bought it two years ago
and it's still you know basically
getting to the stage now where i'm
getting really
frustrated at it but not frustrated
enough to take it apart because i've got
a new console coming
so the fact that it's quiet i'm super
super excited for
i i couldn't play secure on mine because
it would crash so you know i had to do
it
yeah you know i had to do it to him
uh evan we do actually have a picture of
tam photoshopped into that meme i will
send it to you
oh my god oh my god you do
i don't know why i have that image but i
just did oh yeah it's the red face with
the
one thing for e3 yeah yeah yeah
um there is stuff going on around
storage so the teardown video
did show you know like how easy it is to
add extra storage to the playstation
but also there is a bunch of easy easy
there's a bunch of leaks uh because we
haven't seen the ui
um except for those uh kind of leaked
russian videos
um but allegedly looking at the ui the
os takes up
a lot of space and there's only uh
allegedly allegedly allegedly allegedly
664 gigabytes of usable storage space
that is a big yeah three call of duty's
uh at this point i hope that's not true
but i really hope that's not true but
that's the kind of thing that i wish
sony would kind of come out and be like
yeah yeah objection i mean like the
thing is like
because people are gonna say in the
comments it's really easy to plug in
a external hard drive and but the thing
that we don't know is
what does what impact does have that
have on running a game
you know because a lot of the benefits
of you know the new ui
instant loading that kind of stuff will
be using the ssd
and the onboard memory stuff and at
least in the xbox series x's case you
can't do some of the instant loading
and quick resume stuff if it's not on
the ssd the expansion slot if it's on a
external hard drive via usb you lose
some of that
so i imagine that some of that is still
the case for um
ps45 stuff but it would be good mr sony
justin wouldn't it be nice
to know what i've paid for
oh god okay i know actually like this
one is surprisingly a huge
change um in japan so
uh when games come over from japan to
uh western uh in japan
the circle button is proceed cool
the cross button because that's what
they call it weird
x button cross button is actually stop
so um
i actually found this while playing yuck
as a zero the other day in some
instances they forgot to swap
the uh ui which was quite funny and it's
like ingrained in culture so like
they they use that to be like no in
in japan quite a lot and it's like an
extreme now like
okay away from me you know yeah but now
they are bringing it
like they're swapping it to align with
western
anyone anyone who played og metal gear
solid will know
how confusing it was that first time
when people press x
expecting to like hit new game and it
would cancel back it wasn't until
guest solid four i think where they
fixed it shout out to ryan payton
who was on that team um at that time and
now he's at camouflage
who pushed that i believe with a few
others
um on the consumer production team it's
huge like it's
i mean i don't know i just never
anticipated something of that happening
i wonder
why yeah the reasoning even that the
reasoning that they gave
is just like oh yeah it'll just be
easier for us and players will like
adapt to it i'm like i'm not even sure
that's
a good reason i think it's
i think it's one of those annoying small
things that just makes
creating a game a bit of a hassle you
know how like
when you're trying to do like rope work
it's like i have to copy and paste this
hair again
for the 900th time i bet you it's just
like
we just want to fix that and also like
sony as a company is like
skewing a little more western now a lot
of the people in charge a lot of the
studios are a little more western it
makes sense that they would
think about it from a global scale and
keeping it that way
um for japan specifically is probably
just like
they'll get over it we'll figure it out
okay so an actual bit of sony news um
they detailed a blog post about tempest
3d
audio uh the engine how it will so i'm
actually
like i didn't realize this but it will
turn any headset
into 3d audio capable um as long as the
game supports it so obviously all the
first party stuff
resident evil village um so hyperx
you get to live another day my hyperx
headset that only sometimes works uh in
one ear
my my headset is broken and i'm waiting
for that uh that headset to come in so i
can
it's sold out everywhere the new one i'm
just like oh god well the thing is well
this news story means that it's gonna
remain sold out i think because sony has
mentioned that um
it's only to work in headsets uh at
launch
because it won't be working on your
television um
until you know after launch uh and on a
tbd
on that one so it's one of the big
touted features
not being playable like i guess it's
still kind of a win for sony because
people
will want to test the 3d audio they can
just by plugging in headsets
but it is a little bit frustrating i
guess if you have a really sick
setup uh for your sound system and you
can't play it
but i say really i think the bigger
problem is the fact that like we
know so little about playstation and the
fact that sony's just allowing this like
one
somewhat negative thing to just exist
without like countering was like
but all these other things will be
available when the playstation 5
launches
like why have they just not followed
this up with some good news
well it's funny you say good news i
actually have an oh
actually do you want to do a live live
reveal
um i haven't checked my trophies my
trophies were supposed to change
oh is that changing today it was meant
to change on tuesday
oh i hope all my platinums are safe so
uh sony outlined that playstation
trophies
would be um changing like leveling
changes
so now trophy levels don't go from one
to 100
they go from one to nine nine nine um
and also there's a new calculation level
so there's like
oh the playstation app just crashed yeah
it's not it's not connecting
it's not connecting
um so my trophy level earlier was 14
uh still 14. so it hasn't happened yet
mine was mine currently is 291.
all right someone's been gaming
someone's getting it you know why
because i'm a boost
gamer i'm a gamer that's why so
basically what they're doing is
uh trophy levels will have uh different
points allocated to them so like
your bronzes of bronze trophies your
press x to start games
uh will be like between 1 and 99 points
greg miller grow up well no it doesn't
matter because platinums
are regardless worth 999 points
so uh bronze uh yeah one two two nine
nine
silver 300 to 599 gold 600 to 998 and
then 999 for platinum
um and so this just means like trophy
levels are changing
i'm interest like honestly i'm waiting
for that serotonin bump
when i see the number go up uh it's not
worth it i just i just looked at mine i
was like
okay yeah still it's still just a number
whatever um
i got 60 hours into yakuza zero and i
only hit 34
of trophies that's depressing you've got
to do that side stuff you got it i did a
lot of side stuff mate
you didn't do enough yeah keep going
it's not worth it
so the thing the other thing that the
other change that's coming to trophies
is again a little weird slip on sony's
part um
is that trophy tracking is finally
coming
it was it's one of my favorite things
about the xbox one uh
i especially love the way on xbox you
can pin it playing through something
like gears of war and you have a um
you know an achievement then you know do
something 10 times um
it's super satisfying just to pin it
change the opacity on it so it's not
taking over the entire screen and just
work towards something
i sony accidentally put this in a blog
post on the
the french blog post uh and then removed
it
um but it's too late info is already out
there internet is forever
the internet is forever um and
especially when
websites like gamespot.com write it up
it's forever in our archives
i don't know like this is a minor change
but honestly it's a quality of life one
that i've been hoping for for a long
time so i'm excited about it
should we talk about tear down video oh
yeah
bit of a weird one with it yeah it's
very
like uh i mean it makes it makes sense
that they did it and they did the fact
that they
did it is kind of weird in itself they
haven't done an official teardown video
before i think they're just getting
ahead of other people doing it which is
great
um really interesting seeing them pull
that thing apart it's
kind of fascinating in having just re
recently pulled it apart pulled the ps4
apart
um a lot of similar kind of architecture
in terms of how it's all laid out and
shielding and that kind of stuff so it
feels like it should be fairly easy to
get into if you're into that
sort of thing um there's a lot of cool
features in there that i was quite
weirdly into when they showed that a
joke about the fan
mm-hmm that was a temperature feature
joke
let's okay let's let's run through some
of the features oh actually hang on
so i uh when he gave the specs
at the beginning i got out a tape
measure
because um like i said up front like
microsoft has done a really good job
of kind of like showing the xbox in
people's homes
playstation memes of just like people
next to giant giant playstations are
really uh really going out of control
right now
so this is uh 390 millimeters
almost 40 centimeters and i was like how
big is that compared to some things i
have in my house
so uh one second please
the playstation is taller than my air
purifier
damn boy damn boy he's sick
blah that's a thick ass boy damn
anyway playstation's massive uh
so i mean i don't know i still i mean
do you know where you're gonna put yours
yet like that's really tall
so wait hang on that's i'm gonna put my
series x here
and i'm gonna put my playstation over
here
because then i won't have to look at it
yeah like no it's it's because and i've
said this multiple times
all the stuff in my room is like my
monitor my camera
the light everything is black accented
and the fact that the playstation is
white and yes i know he said that you
could take off
the covers um and i was like oh and then
it just looks like an unfinished piece
of machinery if you do that which i was
kind of upset about yeah but like
yeah i think the also the white like
weird shaping is probably going to help
like air flow
it is probably so it's basically the
naruto run
in like form it's makes you aerodynamic
uh r.i.p wraiths naruto run in apex yeah
i don't want to talk about it
unfortunately but no uh so
i'm gonna swap him around this time but
uh so the cooling system
liquid metal
very terminated two of them uh i think
you've actually missed an important one
uh entire rail console is to get hot air
out just like mine
yep ah damn that's what the booty is for
uh so it has dust catches
the playstation 4 is not easy to kind of
uh hoover up dust so like even if you
pull the top off and access the fan um
like when i pulled my pro off so i
pulled i took my pro apart because it
reached a point where i would start a
game and it would
turn off the console and give me a
message saying your ps4 is too hot so
i'd never had that before never seen
that before and it was like
ridiculous so i took it off and the
actual fan was clean
um but when i took all the pieces apart
there were duct pockets everywhere
and the heatsink in particular had a lot
of dust bunnies in there
so the fact that but there was no easy
way for me to just like get a like a uh
you know a handheld vacuum cleaner and
just suck a bunch of it out because
there was no
purchase anywhere so the fact that
they've got a vent now that you can just
basically
use to pull out all the dust is going to
be really really useful
one thing i will say is like the ps5
looks like i didn't look i was i was
watching the teardown video and i didn't
feel
um i felt like i could take it apart if
i needed to it looked like everything
was really built to be able to be
swapped out repaired
much much easier than the playstation 4.
uh also
i just really appreciated the way the
base works the way that you can keep
the uh screw inside the base when you
don't need it
you'd love to see it you see that did
you see the xbox video of them like in
there
uh being cheeky they've taken the now
deleted
um i just imagine phil spencer walk into
a room going
who's doing this well no it was it was
xbox xbox uk did it
yeah but phil can travel instantly oh
yeah
they used images um from the verge which
i really enjoy
like the uk brand doesn't have an xbox
series x to just conclude
you know the you know the vine the
disgusting disgusting imagine that but
with phil spencer
sponsors
and then it got deleted and they got
deleted swiftly but okay so those are
all the little breadcrumbs that we got
revealed
uh they got revealed this week um so the
stuff that we still don't know and i'm
going to make a bold prediction here
that we must be
close to an event i feel it in my bones
so nobelian uh fantastic resource for
gaming news if you follow
nobel on twitter but they were saying
like they went through the
uh the kind of hands-on features um from
japanese person japanese youtubers and
they said they weren't allowed to see
the os
and they weren't allowed to use the
create button so i i
like i'm gonna put on my
prediction hat don't have anything
i should have thought that one through
before you started my prediction hurt
and just say that i think there's an
event coming
yeah i think that create button is going
to be
massive like it's going to not as in
physically huge it's going to be like
it's going to be it's going to be like
so versatile i bet you they are
they have paid a lot of attention to
streaming and also editing clips
i think there will be a dreams i think
dreams
i don't have no no it's in like oh yeah
yeah they're gonna use
create not just for online posting
but i wonder about like this is from an
old ign uk podcast i think it was matt
person talking about it and he was like
you know setting waypoints to where you
are in a game and having your friend
pop in and do the same level as you or
like create your own challenges like
the kind of stuff that they started to
try and do with um
share play yeah i wonder if that's going
to be like
the next level i think baseline like
i bet you if they haven't already i bet
you they have like
basically created a you know adobe
premiere style system
in in playstation 5 like the tech
probably gonna be better than adobe
premiere sucks but like i bet you like
david they'll have like some
comprehensive editing sweet stuff in
there
and like that will be a big reveal like
beanie siegel i can feel it in the air
it's gonna be soon i hope that was a
very specific hip-hop reference
for when yeah but when you said i could
feel it in the air i was like do you not
mean phil collins
no phil collins i'm talking about beanie
put some respect on phil put some
respect on beanie siegel's name that's
what i'm saying
uh but chris pereira uh from
gamespot.com has written a very good
op-ed
where he's he's asking these questions
he's like
yo sony how does the ps5 work it's it's
basically a
about 1 500 words of chris going like
this
yeah but he asks very important
questions and like
it's really good uh so please go read it
we'll link it below
uh lads before we go what is your what
is your big burning question about sony
like what what do you hope if
there's an announcement next week if
don't know anything i'm just assuming
i'm
hoping at this point what do you want to
see
i want to see how that cross save stuff
works like and what is happening to all
my saves are they coming over if i
purchase a thing on ps4 and they decide
to upgrade later is my saves coming with
me
what's going on tell me mr miss
uh nondescript gender sony
about you i just want a confirmation of
what the ui looks like i know we've had
leaks and theories and all this stuff
but i
really want to know what it's going to
look like when i turn my ps5
on for the first time it's a minor thing
but it's something that i really care
about
i want to know what the startup sound is
it's just you hey you should again ah
and with that ah let's call it for today
thank you jordan and tam for joining me
once again
thank you all for watching and uh please
be excited because hopefully sony's
gonna do something again next week we'll
see you then
[Music]
you